Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Nigel, with one mighty wrench, tore his enemy from the deck and hurled him down upon his back. His own head was whirling, and he felt that his senses were slipping away, but already his hunting knife was out and pointing through the slit in the brazen helmet. Give yourself up, fair sir, said he. The dagger tinkled down upon the deck. Seamen and archers ran forward to find Nigel half senseless upon his face. They drew him off, and a few deft blows struck off the helmet of his enemy. A head, sharp-featured, freckled,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。奈杰尔猛地一拽，将他的敌人从甲板上拉了下来，重重地摔在背上。他自己则头晕目眩，感觉意识正在模糊，但他的猎刀已经出鞘，正指着青铜头盔上的缝隙。投降吧，好心的先生，他说。匕首在甲板上叮当作响。水手和弓箭手们跑上前去，发现奈杰尔脸朝下半昏迷着。他们把他拉开，几记熟练的重击便击落了他敌人的头盔。一个轮廓分明、长着雀斑、
and foxy red, disclosed itself beneath it. Nigel raised himself on his elbow for an instant. You are the red ferret, said he. So my enemies call me, said the Frenchman with a smile. I rejoice, sir, that I have fallen to so valiant and honourable a gentleman. I thank you, fair sir, said Nigel feebly. I also rejoice that I have encountered so debonair a person, and I shall ever bear in mind the pleasure which I have had from our meeting. So saying, he laid his bleeding head upon his enemy's brazen front and sank into a dead faint. So Tom Holland, that beautiful passage of prose, the introduction of the red ferret in the book Sir Nigel, which you recommended to me.
有着狐狸般红发的头颅露了出来。奈杰尔用手肘撑着自己，支撑了一会儿。你就是红雪貂，他说。我的敌人们都这么叫我，法国人微笑着说。先生，我很高兴能败在这样一位勇敢而高贵的绅士手下。谢谢你，好心的先生，奈杰尔虚弱地说。我也很高兴能遇到如此风度翩翩的人，我将永远铭记我们相遇的愉快时光。说罢，他把流血的头部靠在敌人青铜般的胸甲上，陷入了彻底的昏迷。托姆·霍兰，那段优美的散文，即你在向我推荐的书籍《奈杰尔爵士》中对“红雪貂”的介绍。
You regard that as one of the great landmarks in Western literature, don't you? I'd completely forgotten the red ferret, and I don't know how I could have done. Yeah, so my father read that to me. It's by Arthur Conan Doyle. Yes. And actually, Arthur Conan Doyle thought that Sir Nigel and the other in the same series, The White Company, were better than Sherlock Holmes. And I'm sure that from the reading you've just given, the listeners will agree with that verdict. Undoubtedly. So Sir Nigel culminates in the Battle of Poitiers, the great victory won by the Black Prince over
你认为那是西方文学的伟大里程碑之一，对吧？我完全把红雪貂这回事给忘了，真不知道我怎么会忘得一干二净。是的，这是我父亲读给我听的。作者是阿瑟·柯南·道尔。是的。事实上，阿瑟·柯南·道尔认为《奈杰尔爵士》以及同系列的另一部作品《白衣军团》甚至比《福尔摩斯》还要出色。我确信，听了你刚才的朗读，听众们也会同意这个评价。毫无疑问。所以《奈杰尔爵士》以普瓦捷战役达到高潮，那是黑太子赢得的伟大胜利，
the French, when they capture the French King. And it filled me with a kind of boyish patriotism, all that kind of stuff. And I became obsessed by The Hundred Years' War. It was one of my great kind of childhood enthusiasms. But it was also the subject of another book that I loved as a child, which gave a very different perspective on the 14th century and The Hundred Years' War, which was A Distant Mirror by Barbara Tuchman, who was probably best known for her books on First World War, so Guns of August and The Proud Tower. She cast The Hundred Years' War, so Guns of August and the Proud Tower. And she cast the Hundred Years' War, unlike Arthur Conan Doyle, as a period of unbelievable suffering. So marked by gangs of mercenaries and freebooters kind of pillaging and destroying, and you've got the Black Death and everything in the background. So for those people who don't know, Tom,
彻底击败了法国人，并俘虏了法国国王。这让我充满了某种孩童般的爱国主义情怀，诸如此类的东西。我开始对百年战争着迷。这是我童年时期的伟大狂热之一。但这也是我童年时期的另一本书的主题，它为14世纪和百年战争提供了一个截然不同的视角，那本书就是芭芭拉·塔奇曼的《远方之镜》，她最著名的作品可能是关于第一次世界大战的《八月炮台》和《自豪的塔楼》。她将百年战争——抱歉，是《八月炮台》和《自豪的塔楼》——与阿瑟·柯南·道尔不同，塔奇曼将百年战争描绘成一个充满难以置信苦难的时期。其标志是雇佣兵和强盗团伙四处劫掠和破坏，背景中还有黑死病和各种灾难。所以，托姆，对于那些不太了解的人来说，
the Hundred Years' War, we are in the 14th and then the 15th century, starting the 14th. It's England versus France. It is the titanic, certainly for English schoolboys of a certain age, it was the colossal titanic showdown between these two diametrically opposed chivalric enterprises. It's the longest war in European history. So it's not even 100 years, it's actually 116 years from 1337 to 1453. In Barbara Tuckman's book, she describes how Edward III, who's the English king, and Philip VI, who is the king of France when England and France go to war, that neither could know that they were opening a war that would outlast both of them,
百年战争跨越了14世纪和15世纪，始于14世纪。交战双方是英格兰和法国。对于某个年龄段的英国男校学生来说，这是一场轰轰烈烈的、绝对史诗级的对决，是这两个截然相反的骑士企业之间的终极较量。这是欧洲历史上持续时间最长的战争。所以它甚至不止100年，实际上长达116年，从1337年一直持续到1453年。在芭芭拉·塔奇曼的书里，她描述了英格兰国王爱德华三世，以及英格兰和法国开战时的法国国王腓力六世，他们当时谁也无法预料，自己开启的这场战争将比他们两人的寿命还要长，
that would develop a life of its own, defying parlies and truces and treaties designed to stop it, that would drag on into their sons' lives and the lives of their grandsons and great-grandsons and great-great-grandsons to the fifth generation that would bring havoc to both sides and become, as its damage spread through Europe, the final torment of the closing Middle Ages. Craig, that's a bit bleak, isn't it? Yeah. So basically it comes in two halves. If you think of it as a football match, the first half, five minutes before halftime, England basically 10-0 up, and then somehow it ends as a draw. Then the same thing happens in the second half. So in this episode, we're going to do
这场战争将发展出它自己的生命力，无视旨在阻止它的会谈、休战和条约，一直拖延到他们儿子的生命、孙子、曾孙以及玄孙的时代，一直延续到第五代，给双方带来浩劫，并随着其破坏力在欧洲蔓延，成为中世纪末期的最终折磨。克雷格，这听起来有点凄凉，不是吗？是的。所以基本上它分为两半。如果你把它想象成一场足球比赛，上半场在临近中场休息前的五分钟，英格兰基本上以10比0领先，然后不知怎的，比赛以平局收场。接着下半场也发生了同样的事情。所以在这一集里，我们要讲述
the build-up to the Hundred Years' War. And then in three episodes that follow, we're going to do that first half. So it features Battle of Crecy, Battle of Poitiers, the collapse of France, and then ultimately Europe into this kind of maelstrom of violence and horror. But it's a very dramatic story. It's also, Tom, is it not the high point of longbows, the black prints, the red ferret, chivalric gestures, debonair knights, maidens, tournaments, all that stuff. That's all here, isn't it? Yes. So this is absolutely par example of the kind of the classic medieval war. So if you like
百年战争的酝酿过程。而在随后的三集里，我们将讲述上半场的内容。其中包括克雷西战役、普瓦捷战役、法国的崩溃，以及最终欧洲陷入这种充满暴力和恐怖的漩涡之中。但这是一个非常戏剧性的故事。而且，托姆，这难道不是长弓、黑太子、红雪貂、骑士风度、风度翩翩的骑士、少女、比武大会等一切事物的最高峰吗？这些元素这里全都有，不是吗？是的。所以这绝对是典型中世纪战争的绝佳范例。因此，如果你喜欢
knights, if you like longbows, this is absolutely the series for you. You might think because France and England fight it for over a hundred years, and because today we think of certainly Britain and France as basically being pretty much par, don't we? I mean, they're kind of pretty much equal weight. I mean, that's not at all the case. And that's why it's so thrilling from an English point of view, is that actually England is a minnow compared to France. So France in the early 14th century is by far the richest country in Europe. It's by far the most populous. It's got six times the income of England, three times the population. And there are records of French visitors coming to
骑士，如果你喜欢长弓，这绝对是为你量身打造的系列。你可能会想，既然法兰西和英格兰打了好几百年，而且今天我们认为英国和法国基本上算是势均力敌，对吧？我的意思是，它们的份量大体相当。然而事实并非如此。这也是为什么从英国的角度来看，这场战争如此惊心动魄的原因——相比于法兰西，英格兰实际上只是个小不点。因此，在14世纪初，法兰西是欧洲最富有的国家，远远甩开其他国家。它也是人口最多的国家。它的收入是英国的六倍，人口是英国的三倍。有记录显示，法国游客来到
England, and they're amazed at how small it is. Well, France has got its magnificent cathedrals, and Paris is the largest city in Western Europe and it's kind of London and England must feel like a backwater. Anyway, Tom, I took you off, sorry, from you. You got to tell us about one of your visitors. Well, yeah. So he says how of the four or five regions into which one could divide the kingdom of France, the poorest would offer more revenue, more towns and cities, more knights and squires than the whole of England. It's the kind of thing that Macron says now. Well, it is, but the French at that point are entirely justified in looking down at England. It pains me to say it, but it's true. Because France is, I mean, it's not just that it's
英格兰时，惊讶于这里竟然如此渺小。好吧，法兰西拥有宏伟的大教堂，巴黎是西欧最大的城市，相比之下，伦敦和英格兰一定让人感觉像个偏远落后的小地方。不管怎样，托姆，抱歉我打断了你。你得给我们讲讲你的其中一位游客。哦，是的。所以他提到，在可以划分法兰西王国的四五个地区中，最贫穷的一个地区所提供的税收、城镇数量、骑士和随从，也比整个英格兰加起来还要多。这简直就是马克龙现在会说的话。好吧，确实如此，但当时的法国人俯视英格兰是完全有底气的。虽然说这话让我感到心痛，但事实确实如此。因为法国不仅仅是
richer and more populous. It's also renowned as the home of chivalry. So it has soft power as well as hard power. The King of Bohemia, who's gone blind at the age of 40, but continues to be a great knight, which is very red ferret kind of territory. Rather than hang out ruling Bohemia, he goes to France because he loves it so much, because he sees this as the true home of chivalry. Everyone's speaking French as their second language. You mentioned the cathedral, so the Gothic style of cathedrals that we have in England. I mean, that comes from France. You mentioned Paris, by far the largest city north of the Alps, by far the most prestigious university. It has, by medieval standards, a very, very effective civil servants, much more effective than the English one. So it's,
更富裕、人口更多。它还作为骑士精神的发源地而闻名遐迩。所以它既拥有软实力，也拥有硬实力。波西米亚国王在40岁时双目失明，但仍然是一位伟大的骑士，这非常符合“红雪貂”式的风格。他没有留在波西米亚统治国家，而是前往法国，因为他太热爱那里了，他视此地为骑士精神真正的故乡。每个人都把法语当作第二语言。你提到了大教堂，我们在英格兰看到的哥特式大教堂风格，其实就是从法国传过来的。你提到了巴黎，它是阿尔卑斯山以北绝对最大的城市，拥有绝对声望最高、按中世纪标准来看效率非常非常高的公务员体系，比英国的公务员体系高效得多。所以，
I mean, it's absolutely the gorilla in the room of medieval Christian kingdoms in the early 14th century. Yeah. It's the United States in the 1950s or something, isn't it? I mean, it's just sort of so glittering, so powerful, so modern. So tell me about the Kings of France, because they're a kind of slightly peculiar bunch, aren't they? It's the dynasty of the Capetians. They've been there since what, 987? I read from your notes. So the Kings of France can ultimately claim their origin all the way back to Clovis, who's this Frankish warlord who seizes what had been Roman Gaul. But the current dynasty of kings in France comes to power in 987, as you said. They get elected, a guy called Hugh Capet. And what's great for the Capetians, the heirs of Hugh Capet, is that to a degree that's really
我的意思是，在14世纪初的中世纪基督教王国中，它绝对是个庞然大物。是的。这就好比20世纪50年代的美国之类的，对吧？我的意思是，它是如此璀璨、如此强大、如此现代化。那么，跟我讲讲法兰西的国王们吧，因为他们是一群有点奇特的人，对吧？这是卡佩王朝。他们从什么时候开始就在那里了，987年吗？我是从你的笔记里读到的。所以法兰西的国王们最终可以把他们的起源一直追溯到克洛维，这个法兰克军阀夺取了曾经的罗马高卢。但正如你所说，法国现任的王室王朝是在987年掌权的。他们选举了一个叫于格·卡佩的人。对于卡佩王朝以及于格·卡佩的继承人们来说，最棒的一点是，在中世纪历史上达到了几乎
unparalleled in medieval history, son follows son, follows son, follows son. 14 kings rule in succession. That's great because it means that you're not slicing and dicing the inheritance and there are no inheritance battles. What that in turn enables the kings to do is to expand their power because what is our understanding of France, say, as a coherent national entity, a nation state, this doesn't remotely correspond to what France is in the early Middle Ages. The kings of France in the 11th century, the 12th century are ruling a 10th of contemporary France. So they call it the royal domain. That's where the king has direct rule. That's around Paris, is it?
无与伦比的程度，父死子继，子继孙承，一代接一代。共有14位国王相继统治。这太棒了，因为这意味着你们不会分割遗产，也没有激烈的继承权之争。这反过来又使国王们能够扩大他们的权力，因为我们对法国的理解——比如作为一个连贯的民族实体或民族国家——这与早期中世纪的法国完全不相符。11世纪和12世纪的法国国王统治的领土只占当代法国的十分之一。所以他们称之为王室领地。那是国王直接统治的地方，就在巴黎附近，对吧？
Around Paris, stretching down to Orléans. It's really very small. The rest of it, so that's about nine-tenths, is ruled by his vassals. I mean, they acknowledge his supremacy, but effectively they're independent. And some of these are very famous because they intrude on English history. So most obviously, Normandy. So that's where William the Conqueror comes from. He's the Duke of Normandy. But also the Duchy of Anjou, that's where Henry II comes from. Of England. Henry II of England. And so the Angevin kings, Henry II, Richard I, John, I mean, they are ruling as much of France as the French kings are. So they've got Normandy, they've got Anjou. They also have, because Henry II marries Eleanor of Aquitaine, they get Aquitaine, which is basically a huge chunk of Southwest France.
围绕着巴黎，一直延伸到奥尔良。真的非常小。其余的部分，也就是大约十分之九，由他的封臣们统治。我的意思是，他们承认他的最高权威，但实际上他们是独立的。其中一些非常著名，因为它们侵入了英国历史。最明显的当然是诺曼底。征服者威廉就是从那里来的，他是诺曼底公爵。还有安茹公国，那是英格兰国王亨利二世的发源地。英格兰的亨利二世。所以安茹王朝的国王们——亨利二世、理查一世、约翰——我的意思是，他们统治的法国领土跟法国国王差不多大。所以他们拥有诺曼底，拥有安茹。由于亨利二世娶了阿基坦的埃莉诺，他们还得到了阿基坦，这基本上是法国西南部的一大片土地。
But they're under the French king, right? They owe him their allegiance or whatever. For some of them, but say not for Aquitaine. So Aquitaine is effectively independent. They acknowledge no overlord. I mean, they recognize that the king of France is the king, but that doesn't mean that they pay homage to him. And that means that France is kind of inherently vociferous. It's a kind of patchwork of duchies, of counties, where the relationship of the rulers to the French king is often kind of, there's whole shades of that. But over the course of the 13th century, a succession of brilliantly able kings are able to not only expand the royal domain, but also to effectively eliminate focuses of opposition to their rule. The most obvious one, of course, is the Angevin kings, Henry II, that dynasty.
但他们还是归法国国王管，对吧？他们要向法国国王效忠之类的。他们中的一些人需要，但比如阿基坦就不需要。所以阿基坦实际上是独立的。他们不承认任何最高领主。我的意思是，他们承认法国国王是国王，但这并不意味着他们要向他行臣服礼。这意味着法兰西本身就具有内在的好斗性。它就像是由公国和伯爵领地拼凑而成的拼图，统治者与法国国王之间的关系往往错综复杂，有着各种各样的微妙之处。但在13世纪期间，一连串才华横溢的英明国王不仅得以扩大王室领地，还实际上消除了对其统治的反对势力。最明显的当然是安茹王朝的国王们，也就是亨利二世那个家族。
And the guy who gets kicked out, who ends up being called Lackland, is John. Normandy gets annexed, all the Loire provinces, all that's left is a tiny chunk of what had been Aquitaine, basically Gascony, centered on Bordeaux, a kind of tiny strip of land stretching southwards from Bordeaux. And that's pretty much all that the kings of England have left of them. We talked about the Albigensian Crusade. And the Cathar Bogos, yeah. So the French kings use that to basically annex directly to their royal domain, Languedoc, Toulouse, all that kind of area.
而那个被赶下台、最后被称为“无地王”的家伙就是约翰。诺曼底被吞并了，所有的卢瓦尔河省份也被吞并，剩下的只有曾经的阿基坦的一小块地方，基本上就是以波尔多为中心的加斯科尼，一小条向南延伸自波尔多的狭长土地。这几乎就是英格兰国王在法国剩下的全部家当了。我们讨论过阿尔比十字军东争。还有卡特里派异端，是的。所以法国国王利用这一点，基本上直接将朗格多克、图卢兹以及所有这些地区吞并到他们的王室领地中。
And also brilliantly in the 13th century, the French annex Champagne and Brie. Right. So they can have champagne and cheese parties. Yeah, very nice. Wine and cheese. Lovely. That's great for the French kings. Yeah.
而且在13世纪，法国人还非常巧妙地吞并了香槟和布里。没错。所以他们可以举办香槟和奶酪派对。太棒了。红酒配奶酪。真美妙。这对法国国王来说太棒了。是的。
So basically by the start of the 14th century, large chunks of France are directly under the rule of the French kings. Yeah. So basically, by the start of the 14th century, large chunks of France are directly under the rule of the French kings. I mean, not all of them. So there are large principalities. So there's Gascony that we mentioned. That's southwest. Yeah. The remnants of the Duchy of Aquitaine.
所以基本上到了14世纪初，法国的大片土地都直接处于法国国王的统治之下。是的。所以基本上，到了14世纪初，法国的大片土地都直接由法国国王统治。当然，并非全部。还有一些大的诸侯国。比如我们提到的加斯科尼，那是西南部。是的，阿基坦公国的残余部分。
There's Brittany. There's Flanders, which is part of the French kingdom, what's now Belgium. So they've got their own dukedoms, haven't they? The Duke of Brittany. Flanders is a dukedom as well, is it? Yes. Or a county? Yeah. Dukedom.
还有布列塔尼。还有佛兰德斯，它是法兰西王国的一部分，也就是现在的比利时。所以他们都有自己的公国，对吧？布列塔尼公爵。佛兰德斯也是个公国，对吧？是的。或者说是一个伯爵领？对，公国。
So they're sort of trying to hold out against the... It's like colossal well i was about to say a game of risk but it's actually obviously a game of thrones tom yeah so game of thrones is a great parallel i mean that's what we're calling this episode if you think of westeros and all the various the seven kingdoms i mean that's kind of the relationship kingdoms of westeros the iron throne the iron throne so the iron throne claims the kind of supremacy over all the seven kingdoms. And just on the Iron Throne, so the person who is on, as it were, the Iron Throne, they call him the most Christian king, don't they? And he is Philip the Fair, is that right? Philip the Fourth? Yeah. Is he an Iron King for an Iron Throne? He pretty much is an Iron King for an Iron Throne, isn't he, Tom? Yes, he is a hard ruler.
所以他们某种程度上试图抵抗……这就像是一场巨大的——我正要说这是一场“风险”棋盘游戏，但实际上它显然是一场“权力的游戏”，托姆。是的，“权力的游戏”是一个极好的类比，我的意思是，这就是我们为这一集起的名字。如果你想想维斯特洛以及各种各样的七大王国，我的意思是，那就是维斯特洛诸王国与铁王座之间的关系。铁王座。因此铁王座宣称对所有七大王国拥有至高无上的权力。就铁王座而言，坐在铁王座上的人，人们称他为“最基督的国王”，对吧？他就是美男子腓力，是这样吗？腓力四世？是的。他是不是铁王座的铁血国王？他几乎就是铁王座的铁血国王，不是吗，托姆？是的，他是一个强硬的统治者。
Right. So he's king from 1285 to 1314. Whether he's faced by foreign rivals or cash flow problems, I mean, he hits solutions hard. So actually he loses a battle to the Flemish infantrymen and it's called the Battle of the Golden Spurs because so many golden spurs are taken from the defeated knights and they get hung up. But Philip isn't having any of that. So he goes in and he smashes up the Flemings, exacts massive reparations, appropriates the city of Lille. So this is when Lille becomes part of the Royal Domain and therefore France in the long run. He expels the Jews from France so he can grab their money. He destroys the Templars, the Knights Templar.
没错。所以他在1285年至1314年期间在位。无论是面对外国对手还是现金流问题，我的意思是，他总是能以雷霆手段解决问题。事实上，他在与佛兰德斯步兵的战斗中打输了一场战役，这场战役被称为金马刺战役，因为人们从战败的骑士身上取下了大量的金马刺并将其悬挂起来。但腓力可不吃这一套。于是他长驱直入，痛击了佛兰德斯人，勒索了巨额赔款，并强行占领了里尔市。所以正是在这个时候，里尔成为了王室领地的一部分，从而从长远来看归入了法国。他将犹太人驱逐出法国以搜刮他们的财富。他摧毁了圣殿骑士团，也就是圣殿骑士。
Oh yeah. And he burns that bloke in front of Notre Dame. Yeah, he does. Jacques de Molay, who was the godfather to his son. And he's doing this again because he needs the money. So just as he expelled the Jews, he's abolishing the Templars. So he gets their cash and he even has a crack at the Pope. He sends French troops in to basically to bully the Pope Boniface VIII and they hold him hostage. And the Pope is so shocked that he dies. And this sets in train a series of events that culminates in the movement of the papacy from Rome to Avignon, which is not part of the Kingdom of France, but obviously is very much on the doorstep of the French kingdom.
哦，是的。他在巴黎圣母院前烧死了那个家伙。是的，他确实这么做了。雅克·德·莫莱，他儿子的教父。他这么做同样是因为他需要钱。正如他驱逐犹太人一样，他取缔了圣殿骑士团，以此来获取他们的资金，他甚至还敢对教皇下手。他派遣法国军队去霸凌教皇博尼法斯八世，甚至将其软禁为人质。教皇大受震惊，竟然活活气死了。这一事件引发了一系列连锁反应，最终导致教皇廷从罗马迁往阿维尼翁。阿维尼翁虽然不属于法兰西王国，但显然就在法兰西王国的家门口。
So again, there's a sense that the papacy has become French. And Frassat, who is the great chronicler of the Hundred Years' War, in his account of the conflict at the beginning, he describes France under Philip the Fair as being gorged, contented, strong. It's people rich and prospering, and not one of them knew the word war. So it's absolutely a golden age. Now, how does this leave the King of England? I was about to say, let's talk about the real heroes of the story now. Well, so the Kings of England, who back in the Angevin period, the time of Henry II and Richard I, had viewed themselves not just as the equals,
因此，人们同样会有一种教皇已经法兰西化的感觉。而作为百年战争伟大编年史家的傅华萨，在其对冲突开端的记述中，将美男子腓力统治下的法国描述为：盛满佳肴、心满意足、国力强盛。人民富庶繁荣，甚至没有人知道“战争”这个词怎么写。所以这绝对是一个黄金时代。那么，这使得英格兰国王处于什么境地呢？我正要说，我们现在来谈谈这个故事真正的英雄吧。好吧，那么英格兰的国王们，他们在安茹王朝时期——也就是亨利二世和理查一世的时代——曾把自己视作不仅与法国国王平等，
but basically superiors of the kings of France, their horizons have very shrunken because they've lost all their holdings in France. And so England in the 13th century has become very marginal. So this is King John, Henry III. Henry III is messing around with Simon de Montfort, and then Edward I and II, I suppose. Is that right? These are pretty much the kings we're talking about. Yeah. Italians will describe them as the little king of England compared to the giant that
甚至还要高出他们一筹，而现在他们的视野大大缩窄了，因为他们失去了在法国的所有领地。因此，13世纪的英格兰变得非常边缘化。所以这就是约翰王、亨利三世。亨利三世跟西蒙·德·孟福尔瞎胡闹，然后是爱德华一世和二世，我想是这样的。对吧？这些差不多就是我们正在谈论的国王。是的。意大利人会把他们形容为“英国的小国王”，相比于
is the king of France. I mean, it's not all bad, I guess, from the English perspective, because obviously having a king who is the king of England and king of vast swathes of France means that England relatively gets neglected. So a king of England who really is only just the king, aside from his tiny strip of Gascony, is basically the king of England. I think it helps to consolidate a sense of national unity. So Sir Nigel, I mean, a more modern Nigel would very much applaud this, right? They would say, this is England for the English. It's literally Little England. It's like, forget the foreign entanglements. Let's just concentrate on our own sense of national identity and who cares about the French stuff. Is there a bit of
法兰西国王这个庞然大物。不过从英国的角度来看，事情也并非全都是坏事，因为显然，拥有一个既是英格兰国王又是法兰西大片领土国王的君主，意味着英格兰在相对意义上会被忽视。所以，一个实际上只勉强算是个国王——除了他那加斯科尼的小狭长地带之外——基本上只是英格兰国王的君主，我认为这有助于巩固一种民族统一感。所以奈杰尔——我的意思是，一个更现代的奈杰尔会非常赞同这一点，对吧？他们会说，这是英国人的英国。这就是字面意义上的“小英格兰”。就好像是，忘掉那些海外纠葛吧。让我们专心于我们自己的民族认同感，谁管法国人的事呢。这其中是不是有一点
an element of that, do you think, developing? So England as a kingdom that's on an island is geographically more homogeneous. But you mentioned Sir Nigel. I mean, the English are famous throughout Christendom in this period for their xenophobia, their kind of hostility to going abroad. And obviously this is true of the mass of the people. The nobility is still very, very attracted to French examples. But even among them, these are the heirs of people who came over with William the Conqueror, they're starting to lose French as a first language. And so Frasso, when he's writing about the dealings of English diplomats with the French in the 14th century, he says that often when the English run into trouble, they'll pretend that they don't understand what the French
这种元素在发展呢？所以作为一个岛国，英国在地理上更加同质化。但你提到了奈杰尔。我的意思是，这一时期的英国人以整个基督教世界闻名的排外情绪而著称，他们有一种不愿出国的不满情绪。显然，广大民众确实如此。但贵族阶层仍然非常非常受法国范例的吸引。即便在他们当中，作为征服者威廉随行人员的后代，人们也开始逐渐不再将法语作为第一语言。因此，当傅华萨在书写14世纪英国外交官与法国人打交道的经历时，他说，通常当英国人遇到麻烦时，他们就会假装听不懂法国人在
are saying. Increasingly, they have English names. Edward would be the classic example, or indeed Thomas, a splendid name. Well, Edward is a really interesting one because that's obviously an Anglo-Saxon name, isn't it? And the kings of England, the Plantagenet kings, are now adopting Anglo-Saxon names. So they have become Anglicised in a way that they wouldn't have been a few generations earlier. They are, although the kings of England are in a way a special case because they do continue to speak French as their first language. And also they absolutely still see themselves as peers of France and as major continental players. So there is something of British prime ministers in the
说些什么。他们越来越多地拥有英国名字。爱德华就是一个典型的例子，或者还有托马斯，一个极其漂亮的名字。好吧，爱德华是一个非常有趣的例子，因为这显然是一个盎格鲁-撒克逊名字，对吧？而且英格兰的国王们——金雀花王朝的国王们——现在正在采用盎格鲁-撒克逊名字。所以他们已经实现了本土化，这是他们在几代人之前所不会有的转变。他们的确如此，尽管英格兰的国王们在某种程度上是个特例，因为他们确实继续将法语作为他们的第一语言。而且他们绝对仍然认为自己是法国的同等贵族，是欧洲大陆的重要玩家。因此，这有点像第二次世界大战后
wake of the Second World War still wanting to believe that they are the leaders of a great power, of a superpower. Kings like, certainly, Edward I are very reluctant to acknowledge their diminished status. To be honest, they certainly have continuing stakes in France in a way that, say, the French king does not in England. They have stakes in both the two autonomous principalities, Flanders and Brittany. Flanders is the great center of weaving, and the weaving depends on English wool. That relationship between England and Flanders, I suppose, Belgium, Northern Belgium, is a fascinating one, isn't it? Because we did a
英国首相们的心态，他们依然渴望相信自己是一个大国、一个超级大国的领导人。像爱德华一世这样的国王，极不情愿承认自己地位的下降。老实说，他们确实在法国持续保持着利益，而法国国王在英国则没有这种利益。他们在两个自治公国——佛兰德斯和布列塔尼——中都拥有权益。佛兰德斯是著名的织造业中心，而织造业依赖于英国的羊毛。英格兰和佛兰德斯（我猜也就是现在的比利时，北部比利时）之间的这种关系非常迷人，不是吗？因为我们曾经和巴特·范·洛一起做过
podcast about Burgundy with Bart Van Loo, and he was talking about how in the 15th century, there was almost a natural English-Burgundian alliance. Because that economic relationship about wool is so important, does that mean that in this period, there's an automatic political relationship as well? I think not for the Counts of Flanders, and they are Counts. Sorry, I said Dukes earlier. There's so many Dukes and Counts, it's very confusing. That was my fault, Tom. I dragged you into a Duke morass. The Counts of Flanders, they're not interested in wool and weaving, but there's this kind of proto-industrial revolution happening in Flanders. And so the cities that is the home of
一期关于勃艮第的播客，他谈到在15世纪，几乎存在着一种天然的英格兰-勃艮第联盟。因为这种关于羊毛的经济关系如此重要，这是否意味着在此期间，也存在着一种自动的政治关系呢？我认为对于佛兰德斯伯爵来说并非如此，而且他们是伯爵。抱歉，我刚才说的是公爵。有太多的公爵和伯爵了，这太容易让人搞混了。那是我的错，托姆。我把你拖进了一个公爵的泥潭。佛兰德斯伯爵们对羊毛和织造并不感兴趣，但佛兰德斯正在发生一种类似于准工业革命的变革。因此，作为
the weavers are becoming more and more autonomous, more and more significant. That means that the kings of England who supply the raw material are finding that this gives them a way of affecting and influencing opinion in Flanders. So they can kind of impose trade blockades. And this is a weapon that over the course of the 13th century into the 14th century, that they're not reluctant to use. And so that gives them a point of leverage over, Flanders is by far the richest of the various regions of France. So that does give them a kind of throttle hold. The Kings of England have a very close relationship with the Dukes of Brittany because the brilliantly named Alan of Brittany, he'd come over with William the Conqueror and been given lands. And so this is part of inheritance. One of them is the Duke of Brittany
织工家园的那些城市变得越来越自治，越来越重要。这意味着供应原材料的英格兰国王们发现，这为他们提供了一种影响和左右佛兰德斯舆论的途径。因此他们可以实施贸易封锁。这是他们在13世纪到14世纪期间一直乐于使用的武器。这赋予了他们对佛兰德斯的某种筹码，要知道佛兰德斯是法国各个地区中最富有的。所以这确实赋予了他们一种扼制的力量。英格兰国王与布列塔尼公爵有着非常密切的关系，因为那个名字极其响亮的布列塔尼人阿兰曾随征服者威廉一同来到英国并被册封了土地。所以这也是继承权的一部分。其中一位布列塔尼公爵
is the Earl of Richmond. Richmond is the seat of Rishi Sunak, so in Yorkshire. And the entirety of holdings in England that the Dukes of Brittany have probably is giving them a greater income than they're getting from Brittany itself. An example of how intimate the relations between the Ducal family of Brittany and the English king is provided by a guy called John, Jean, in the early 14th century, who's the uncle of the Duke of Brittany in that time. But he's also a peer who sits in the House of Lords. He fights with the English armies against the Scots, actually against the French as well. He's godfather to the future, Edward III. So there are absolutely very, very important links there. Yeah. I think Brittany should still be part of England, to be quite frank with you, but that's a
同时也是里士满伯爵。里士满是里希·苏纳克的选区，位于约克郡。布列塔尼公爵在英国拥有的全部资产，所带来的收入可能比他们从布列塔尼本土获得的还要多。布列塔尼公国家族与英国国王之间关系有多么亲密，14世纪初的一个名叫让（Jean）的家伙就是一个很好的例子，他是当时布列塔尼公爵的叔叔。但他也是一位坐在英国上议院的贵族。他曾与英国军队并肩作战对抗苏格兰人，实际上也对抗过法国人。他是未来国王爱德华三世的教父。所以这里绝对存在着非常非常重要的联系。是的。坦白说，我认为布列塔尼应该依然是英国的一部分，但这只是一个
niche opinion. I know, go on, Tom. Well, and also just to reiterate, the English kings do have direct holding. So they do have Gascony. And also from the time of Edward I, they have this region called Pontieux, which is just south of Calais, which they've kind of inherited by marriage. So what about Aquitaine?
小众观点。我知道，继续说吧，托姆。好吧，还要重申一点，英国国王确实拥有直接领地。所以他们确实拥有加斯科尼。而且从爱德华一世时代起，他们还拥有一个叫做蓬蒂厄的地区，就在加来正南方，这是他们通过联姻继承的。那么阿基坦呢？
So Eleanor of Aquitaine, famously, you know, tremendous heiress, brought all these lands, all this money. Have we still got Aquitaine? We have, but very precariously, kind of clinging on with our fingernails. I say our, the English kings are. Henry III, who's a bit of, to be honest, not the most charismatic and forward thinking of English kings, he basically arrives at a compromise that is in effect a disaster. So in 1259, he signs a treaty, the Treaty of Paris, which means that the French kings acknowledge their rule over this kind of the rump of what had been Aquitaine Gascony. But in return, Henry III is obliged to pay homage for it. This is signed with the aim of establishing kind of concord and peace between the two kings, but it doesn't have that effect because in the long run, Henry III hadn't realized it, but Edward I, his much more swaggering son, absolutely does. What this means is that his subjects in Gascony can appeal over his head
所以阿基坦的埃莉诺，众所周知，是一位了不起的女继承人，带来了所有这些土地和财富。我们现在还有阿基坦吗？我们还有，但非常勉强，简直是用指甲死死抠住不放。我说的“我们”是指英国国王。亨利三世——老实说，他算不上英国国王中最具个人魅力和远见卓识的一位——他基本上达成了一个实际上堪称灾难的妥协。因此在1259年，他签署了一项条约，即《巴黎条约》，这意味着法国国王承认他对曾经的阿基坦（加斯科尼）残余领地的统治。但作为交换，亨利三世被迫为此行臣服礼。签署这项条约的目的是为了在两位国王之间建立某种和谐与和平，但它并没有产生这种效果，因为从长远来看，亨利三世并没有意识到这一点，但他那位更加趾高气昂的儿子爱德华一世绝对意识到了。这意味着他在加斯科尼的臣民可以越过他，直接上诉
to the French king. So in other words, he's not mastering his own domain. And also it's humiliating for a king to pay homage to another king. That's absolutely what Edward feels. And so Edward, who is the hammer of the Scots, the guy who conquers Wales, I think there's absolutely a sense in which he is looking to expand the borders of England within the, yeah. So a couple of questions before we go to a break. Presumably, if you're the English king, no matter whether you're Henry III or Edward I or whoever, because France is so rich and so culturally prestigious, you would much prefer to expand your domains in France than to be conquering-
到法国国王那里。换句话说，他无法掌控自己的领地。而且，一个国王向另一个国王行臣服礼是极其屈辱的。爱德华绝对就是这么想的。因此，作为“苏格兰之锤”、征服威尔士的那个男人，爱德华绝对有一种想要在……范围内扩大英格兰边界的心态。所以，在进入中场休息之前有几个问题。假设你是英国国王，无论你是亨利三世、爱德华一世还是其他什么人，由于法国是如此富裕且文化声望如此之高，你肯定会更倾向于在法国扩张领地，而不是去征服——
Scotland. Yeah, Carnarvon or Edinburgh or whatever. You know, it's not just Scotland and Wales. It's England as well. It's seen whatever. You know, it's not just Scotland and Wales. It's England as well. It's seen as being, well, it's not France. I mean, who wouldn't want to have a bit of France? So France is the kind of the metropole, if you like, and these places are peripheral powers. It's richer.
苏格兰。对吧，卡纳芬或爱丁堡之类的地方。你知道的，这不仅仅是苏格兰和威尔士的问题。这也是英格兰的问题。它被视为什么什么。你知道的，这不仅仅是苏格兰和威尔士。这也是英格兰的问题。它被视为，好吧，它又不是法国。谁不想拥有法国的一小部分呢？所以法国可以说是大都市，如果你愿意这么称呼的话，而这些地方则是边缘势力。它更富裕，
It's more prosperous. It's more prestigious. And it's the home of chivalry. Okay. And certainly the English kings feel they want to be a part of this. They'd much rather have Normandy or Anjou than they would have, say, I don't know, Southern Scotland or Wales, or maybe even Surrey. Just on the English kings, the English kings think of themselves as English or as French, or both? They think of themselves as kings of England. And so they are absolutely
它更繁荣，它更有声望，而且它是骑士精神的发源地。好的。而且英国国王们当然觉得他们想要成为其中的一部分。他们宁愿要诺曼底或安茹，也不愿要，比方说，我不知道，苏格兰南部或威尔士，甚至可能是萨里郡。顺便问一下关于英国国王的问题，英格兰的国王们认为自己是英国人还是法国人，还是两者皆有？他们认为自己是英格兰国王。所以他们绝对是在
identifying themselves, as we will see with the legends of England, of Britain, with King Arthur, all that kind of thing. But they see themselves as well as being players in French politics, as being peers of the great figures of the French court. So they are absolutely torn, I think. I mean, I don't think they'd be conscious of themselves being torn because I don't think that they would be thinking that English and French are absolute categories in the way that we would. So these are not nation states? These are not nation states. I mean, England is much more approximating to a nation state than France is, but this is not really how the kings of England see it, I think.
认同自己，正如我们接下来将看到的关于英国和不列颠的传说那样，他们与亚瑟王以及诸如此类的事物联系在一起。但他们同样认为自己是法国政治的参与者，是法国宫廷伟大人物的同辈贵族。所以他们绝对是分裂的，我认为。我的意思是，我不认为他们会意识到自己是分裂的，因为我不认为他们会像我们今天这样，把“英国人”和“法国人”视为绝对的分类。所以这些还不是民族国家？这些还不是民族国家。我的意思是，英国比法国更接近于民族国家，但这并不是英国国王们看待它的方式，我认为。
That question that I just asked, they wouldn't understand the question because they would say- Probably not. You can absolutely be English and French because French is a sort of different category almost. Is that right? Would that be right? Just like you can be Norman and French or Breton and French. Absolutely. The mass of people in England think of themselves as English, but the kings of England are operating
我刚刚问的那个问题，他们根本无法理解，因为他们会说——可能不会。你完全可以既是英国人又是法国人，因为“法国人”几乎是一种不同的类别。是这样的吗？会是这样吗？就像你可以既是诺曼人又是法国人，或者既是布列塔尼人又是法国人一样。绝对如此。英国的普通民众认为自己是英国人，但英国国王们的行事方式
in a more elevated, more complex, more historically informed sense of themselves. They're part of a wider international global elite, aren't they? Well, they're kings by definition. But the tournaments and all that kind of thing, I know this is a stupid comparison. They are the sort of Davos get togethers. I suppose. Of the day, right? The very rich people go to and they have a lingua franca, which is French. They move in a different kind of cultural universe from the people that they rule. So rather than kind of meeting up and talking about what does AI mean for global finance, they would compete in the lists, tournaments, all that kind of thing.
基于一种更高阶、更复杂、更具历史意识的自我认知。他们属于一个更广泛的国际全球精英阶层，不是吗？好吧，他们按定义就是国王。但那些比武大会和所有诸如此类的事情——我知道这是一个愚蠢的类比。它们就像是那种达沃斯论坛的聚会。我想是的。当天的聚会，对吧？非常富有的人去那里，他们拥有一种通用语，那就是法语。他们生活在一种与他们所统治的人完全不同的文化宇宙中。因此，与其说他们聚在一起讨论人工智能对全球金融意味着什么，不如说他们会在竞技场上、在比武大会中一较高下，诸如此类。
Exactly. One other thing I want to talk about, which is wine. So you mentioned we still have Gascony, we still have Bordeaux. So presumably wine is quite a big factor in all this, is it? The wine trade must be significant. We are importing claret or whatever. Why the obsession with Bordeaux in England? Yes. So it's about 80,000 tons of wine are being exported annually to England. And so again, that gives incredible leverage. So the two kind of great export industries of France,
没错。还有一件事我想谈谈，那就是葡萄酒。所以你提到我们还有加斯科尼，我们还有波尔多。因此，想必葡萄酒在这其中是一个相当大的因素，对吧？葡萄酒贸易一定相当重要。我们在进口克乐亭红酒或其他什么。为什么英国人对波尔多如此执着？是的。所以大约有8万吨葡萄酒每年被出口到英国。因此，这同样赋予了他们难以置信的筹码。因此，法国的两个伟大出口产业——
the Flemish wool and the wines of bordeaux are both absolutely intimately fused with with england but it's an unstable relationship because of this issue of the paying homage and because of the power and balance between the two and because of the aspirations of the because the french court obviously has an aspiration to kind of spread french power over france and the english kings have an aspiration to preserve and indeed widen their own- Claw it back. Yeah. So that's the basic instability, would you say?
佛兰德斯的羊毛和波尔多的葡萄酒——都与英国紧密地融合在一起。但这是一段不稳定的关系，因为行臣服礼的问题，因为两者之间的权力平衡，以及因为……由于法国宫廷显然有一种雄心，想要将法国的权力扩展到整个法国，而英国国王们则有一种雄心，要保留并实际上扩大他们自己的——把它们夺回来。是的。所以这就是基本的不稳定性，你会这么认为吗？
The aspirations of the rival courts. Yeah. Brilliant. Well, we should take a break, I think, Tom. And I believe we're going to come back in with one of my very favorite English kings. Not a good king, it's fair to say, but an interesting king. Because we're going to come back in with one of my very favourite English kings. Not a good king, it's fair to say, but an interesting king, because we're going to come back in with Edward II. Is that right?
两大宫廷的雄心壮志。太棒了。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了，托姆。我相信我们回来时，将迎来我最喜欢的英国国王之一。坦白说，他不是个好国王，但却是个有趣的国王。因为我们将带着爱德华二世回归。是这样吗？
Yeah, described by one of his biographers in 1900 as an absolute ninny. An absolute ninny. We're going to return with an absolute ninny, Edward II. So come back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
是的，被一位19世纪末的传记作家形容为一个十足的傻瓜。一个十足的傻瓜。我们将带着一个十足的傻瓜——爱德华二世回归。所以休息之后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We promised you we would return with King Edward II, and we have. Tom has just said to me in the break, tell everybody about Edward II, because clearly he doesn't know anything about him. So, Tom, to educate you and the audience,
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们向你承诺过，我们将带着爱德华二世国王回归，我们做到了。托姆在休息时刚刚对我说：“快跟大家讲讲爱德华二世吧，因为他显然对这个人一无所知。”所以，托姆，为了教育你和听众们，
Edward II was a useless king. Doesn't he appear in Braveheart? He's in Braveheart, isn't he? He gets cuckolded by William Wallace. He does. He's married to Sophie Marceau in Braveheart. In reality, he is indeed beaten at the Battle of Bannockburn in Scotland, Edward II. So his father, Edward I, is an incredibly formidable fellow, the Hammer of the Scots.
爱德华二世是个无能的国王。他是不是出现在《勇敢的心》里？他在《勇敢的心》里，对吧？他被威廉·华莱士戴了绿帽子。他确实是的。他在《勇敢的心》里娶了苏菲·玛索。现实中，爱德华二世确实在苏格兰的班诺克本战役中被打败了。所以他的父亲爱德华一世是一个极其可怕的狠角色，也就是“苏格兰之锤”。
Edward II, useless, great domestic instability at home. There's all these favourites on the endless favourites. Waves of them. This is very 1066 and all that. There's the dispensers. There's obviously no notoriously Piers Gaveston with whom he was supposed to have been infatuated. And Edward II's weakness. Now, why is that a problem? Why does that destabilise things? Because obviously from the French point of view, I mean, that's great that he's so weak. Why would that change the relationship between England and France, Tom? So Scotland has, since 1295, been in alliance with France. This is the old alliance. And essentially, by its terms, it's stipulated that if either Scotland
而爱德华二世则很无能，国内政治极度不稳定。身边全都是各种幸臣——无数的幸臣。这非常符合《1066及其所有》的风格。有德斯潘瑟父子。显然还有臭名昭著的皮尔斯·加弗斯顿，据说爱德华二世对之迷恋不已。而爱德华二世的软弱。现在，为什么这是一个问题？为什么这会破坏局势稳定？因为很明显，从法国的角度来看，他这么软弱简直太棒了。为什么这会改变英格兰和法国之间的关系呢，托姆？所以自1295年以来，苏格兰一直与法国结盟。这就是“老同盟”。从本质上讲，该条约规定，如果苏格兰
or France get attacked by England, then the other country will invade England. For English kings who are looking to France, that creates an inherent sense of instability in the North. In Shakespeare's play Henry V, Henry describes the weasel Scot, this idea that you head off and the weasel will come in and nick all your eggs. Got it. It's the kind of idea. We've had the red ferrets, now we've got the Scottish weasel. Yes. So Edward II, as you said, you mentioned Braveheart, is married to a French queen.
或法国遭到英格兰的进攻，那么另一个国家就会入侵英格兰。对于将目光投向法国的英国国王来说，这在北方造成了一种内在的不稳定感。在莎士比亚的戏剧《亨利五世》中，亨利将苏格兰人描述为“狡猾的黄鼠狼”，这种想法就是：你带兵出征，而黄鼠狼会乘虚而入，偷走你所有的鸡蛋。明白了。我们之前有了“红雪貂”，现在又有了“苏格兰黄鼠狼”。是的。所以正如你所说，你提到了《勇敢的心》，爱德华二世娶了一位法国王后。
She is the youngest daughter of Philip IV, who we mentioned, Philip the Fair. And they have a son who they call Edward. Surprise, surprise. Shockingly, Isabella's, so the queen is called Isabella. Her uncle wanted Edward to be called Louis. Oh no, you couldn't have an English king called Louis. Yeah. They unfortunately hate each other.
她是腓力四世（也就是我们提到的美男子腓力）的小女儿。他们有一个儿子，他们给他起名叫爱德华。不出所料。令人震惊的是，伊莎贝拉的——所以王后叫伊莎贝拉。她的叔叔曾想让爱德华叫路易。哦不，你可不能让一个英国国王叫路易。是的。不幸的是，他们互相憎恨对方。
So is she the she-wolf of France? That is the name that is given to her. She's not quite as she-wolfish as that reputation might suggest. She's actually very kind of pious, but she really comes to hate Edward II with disastrous consequences, as we will see. Because the sense the French have that Edward II is messing up inevitably means that they see it as a chance to kind of snip away at Gascony, despite the Treaty of Paris saying that they won't do this. And so Philip the Fair appoints a commission. He's investigating what he describes as the violence, the looting, the rapine and the anarchy in Aquitaine. So basically he's kind of
所以她是法国的母狼吗？人们就是这么叫她的。她其实并不像那个名声所暗示的那么像母狼。她其实非常虔诚，但正如我们所见，她真的开始痛恨爱德华二世，并带来了灾难性的后果。因为法国人感觉到爱德华二世把事情搞砸了，这不可避免地意味着他们认为这是一个蚕食加斯科涅的好机会，尽管《巴黎条约》规定他们不会这么做。因此，腓力四世任命了一个委员会。他在调查他所描述的阿基坦的暴力、掠夺、强盗行径和无政府状态。所以基本上他是在
saying, this is a failed state, therefore we have the right to come in and annex it for the good of everybody. Is it a failed state or is that all, is this fake news? It is fake news. I mean, it's not in a great state, but it's not so bad that Philip would be justified in annexing it. And so what Philip then does is to demand that Edward come and do him homage for it. And Edward keeps trying to kind of, again, weasel out of it. And this gives the French the chance to move in. So 1324, they invade Aquitaine and they overrun pretty much all of it except for Bordeaux. And the following year, Edward II is informed that unless he comes and does his homage immediately, then the entire duchy will be forfeit. The French king will annex it completely. And he's also
说，这是一个失败的国家，因此我们有权为了每个人的利益介入并将其吞并。这是一个失败的国家，还是这一切、这都是假新闻？这就是假新闻。我的意思是，它的状况虽然不是很好，但还没糟到腓力有理由吞并它的地步。因此，腓力接着做的事就是要求爱德华来为这片领地向他效忠。而爱德华一直在试图再次、再次企图蒙混过关。这给了法国人趁虚而入的机会。所以在1324年，他们入侵了阿基坦，除了波尔多之外，他们几乎占领了那里的一切。第二年，爱德华二世接到通知，除非他立刻来宣誓效忠，否则整个公国将被没收。法国国王将彻底吞并它。他还
informed via papal back channels that he should send his wife, his queen Isabella, to do the negotiating. So she's a member of the French royal family. That's a very bad idea because she's kind of party pre, isn't she? I mean, isn't she? She is. She can't be relied upon. Yeah. And an additional problem is that there's a guy in Paris called Roger Mortimer, who is in exile from England, who also hates Edward. She goes to Paris and immediately shacks up with him. So this is ominous for Edward II.
通过罗马教廷的地下渠道得知，他应该派他的妻子、王后伊莎贝拉去进行谈判。所以她是法国王室成员。这是一个非常糟糕的主意，因为她有点偏心，不是吗？我是说，难道不是吗？是的。她根本信不过。是的。还有一个额外的问题，巴黎有个叫罗杰·莫蒂弗的人，他是从英国流亡出去的，他也恨爱德华。她去了巴黎，并立刻跟他同居了。这对爱德华二世来说是个不祥之兆。
He then commits the cardinal mistake of deciding that rather than going and paying homage himself, he will send his son, Edward. So Edward goes over to Paris and Isabella and Mortimer snaffle him and refuse to send him back. And they prepare to invade England. And they're busy kind of preparing for the future. They go to a place called Hainaut, which is kind of border of Flanders and France. And there, the young Edward meets with a young girl called Philippa, Philippa of Hainaut, second daughter of the Count of Hainaut. They get on tremendously well and they and they get pledged to each other. He's 12 and she's similar age? She's 12 as well. Right. Philippa's so keen on Edward that when Edward leaves, she bursts into tears.
接着他犯了一个致命的错误，他决定与其自己去宣誓效忠，不如派他的儿子爱德华去。于是爱德华去了巴黎，伊莎贝拉和莫蒂默把这个小家伙扣下，拒绝把他送回来。他们准备入侵英国。他们正忙着为未来做准备。他们去了一个叫埃诺的地方，那有点像弗兰德斯和法国的边境。在那里，年轻的爱德华遇到了一个叫菲莉帕的年轻女孩，埃诺的菲莉帕，埃诺伯爵的二女儿。他们相处得极为融洽，并向对方许下了承诺。他12岁，她也差不多大？她也是12岁。对。菲莉帕对爱德华如此喜爱，以至于爱德华离开时，她放声大哭。
Oh, that's quite a nice story, Tom. Yeah. Isabella and Mortimer invade England, taking the young Edward with them. They overthrow Edward II. Edward II abdicates. He then ends up horribly murdered in Berkeley Castle. Just as a quick spoiler, in case we ever do an episode on Edward II, is it or is it not correct that he is murdered by having, I mean, you talked about the papal back channels. Is there not some issue with the red hot poker and the back channel? That is the story. I mean, there are various accounts. Actually, Ian Mortimer, historian of medieval England, who wrote a fabulous book about both Mortimer and Edward III, has a theory that Edward II never actually died.
哦，那真是个不错的动人故事，汤姆。是的。伊莎贝拉和莫蒂默入侵英国，把年轻的爱德华带在身边。他们推翻了爱德华二世。爱德华二世退位。最后他在伯克利城堡遭到极其残忍的谋杀。作为一个快速剧透，以防我们以后做一期关于爱德华二世的节目，他被谋杀的方式是不是——我是说，你刚才提到了罗马教廷的地下渠道——难道关于红热火钳和地下渠道没有什么骇人听闻的传闻吗？那就是流传的故事。我的意思是，有各种各样的说法。事实上，中世纪英国历史学家伊恩·莫蒂默写了一本关于莫蒂默和爱德华三世的精彩书籍，他有一个理论，认为爱德华二世其实从未真正死去。
Oh yeah, I've seen that. He's written lots of very angry articles about him. I'm not entirely convinced by that, but maybe we'll come to that if we do an episode on Edward II. Anyway, so basically, Edward II gets disposed of. Mortimer and Isabella are the effective rulers of England, and they use the young Edward III as their puppet. So are they in cahoots with the King of France? That's the question. Yes, they are. So basically, England has been reduced to a French puppet at this point, has it? To some degree? Yeah.
哦，是的，我见过那个。他写了许多关于他的非常愤怒的文章。我对此并不是完全信服，但如果我们做一期关于爱德华二世的节目，也许我们会谈到这一点。无论如何，基本上，爱德华二世被废黜了。莫蒂默和伊莎贝拉成了英国的实际统治者，他们把年轻的爱德华三世当作他们的傀儡。那么他们跟法国国王是一伙的吗？这就是问题所在。是的，他们是。所以基本上，英国在这个时候已经沦为一个法国傀儡了吗？在某种程度上？是的。
Yeah, effectively. And Edward absolutely has been reduced to a puppet. And he hates this. Young Edward III. The young Edward. I mean, he's an absolute uh he's more than a lad he's a jock he's a jock he really is he's like the captain of the rugby team yeah so so i mean he's obsessed with with tournaments so he has absolutely all the best gear best armor just everything i'm just looking at ian mortimer's book the perfect king horbucks greaves lances bassinets with visors gauntuntlets, trousers and breeches. I mean, I've got trousers.
是的，实际上是的。爱德华绝对已经沦为一个傀儡了。他对此恨之入骨。年轻的爱德华三世。年轻的爱德华。我的意思是，他绝对是个呃他不仅仅是个小伙子他是个运动健将他是个运动健将真的就像橄榄球队队长一样所以所以我的意思是——他沉迷于比武大会，所以他绝对拥有最好的装备、最好的盔甲，总之应有尽有。我正在看伊恩·莫蒂默的书《完美国王》：护喉甲、护胫甲、长矛、带面罩的巴斯德盔、铁手套、裤子和马裤。我的意思是，我有裤子。
Many other items are personal. I'm already aware. Decorated acatons. What's an acaton, Tom? No idea. Gilded lances, tournament armor decorated with images of flowers and animals, leopards and crowns. It took part in five tournaments at the age of 14.
许多其他物品都是私人的。我早就知道了。饰有图案的软甲。软甲是什么，汤姆？不知道。镀金长矛，饰有花朵和动物图案的比武盔甲，还有豹子和皇冠。他在14岁时就参加了五次比武大会。
Yeah. So it is, I mean, it is kind of like, you know, high school football. Right. He at the age of 14. Yeah. So it is kind of like high school football. Right. He's the guy with all the kit. Yeah. Who's whatever it is you do in American football. You just basically run into each other. Touchdowns, is it?
是的。所以这有点像，你知道的，高中橄榄球。对。他14岁的时候。是的。所以这有点像高中橄榄球。对。他就是那个装备齐全的家伙。对。无论你在美式橄榄球里做什么。你们基本上就是撞在一起。是达阵吗？
I don't know, whatever. Yeah. So that's basically him. And so you can imagine that he doesn't like being put in the shadow of an upstart guy like Mortimer. No. And things don't go well with the Scots. You amaze me.
我不知道，随便吧。是的。这基本上就是他。所以你可以想象他不喜欢被像莫蒂默这样的暴发户压制在阴影之下。没错。而且和苏格兰人的关系进展得并不顺利。你可真让我惊讶。
So 1328, Mortimer goes off to try and whip the Scots into shape and it goes disastrously wrong. It's all very humiliating. Mortimer ends up signing a treaty with the Scots that effectively ends the Wars of Independence that have been raging since the time of Edward I, in which Edward III is obliged to acknowledge the independence of Scotland. And he does not like this at all. Nobody in England likes it. They come to call it the shameful peace. It inspires Edward to think, well, I've got to get rid of this guy. So in 1330, a group of his friends, so Edward III is a great one for friends. He likes to surround himself with the
所以在1328年，莫蒂默去试图让苏格兰人老实点，结果却糟透了。这非常屈辱。莫蒂默最终与苏格兰人签署了一项条约，实际上结束了自爱德华一世时期以来一直在激战的独立战争，在条约中，爱德华三世被迫承认苏格兰的独立。他对此非常反感。英国没有一个人喜欢这样。他们开始称之为“耻辱的和解”。这激发了爱德华的想法，嗯，我必须除掉这家伙。所以在1330年，他的一群朋友——爱德华三世很喜欢结交朋友。他喜欢让周围环绕着
lads. 1330, all the guys, all the boys, the boys get together and they stage a coup and Mortimer gets toppled. He gets executed and Edward III lays claim. He fulfills his destiny. I think that's a very good voice that you do, but I'm really glad you're not going to do the rest of the podcast in that voice. No, I'm not. And it matters because these guys who have basically helped Edward to topple Mortimer are people who will play a key role in the story of his reign. He doesn't forget what he owes them. And it's like the rugger team that win whatever it is. What do rugger teams win?
小伙子们。1330年，所有这些哥们儿、所有的男孩们，男孩们聚在一起发动了一场政变，莫蒂默被推翻了。他被处决了，爱德华三世宣示了权力。他实现了自己的命运。我觉得你刚才模仿的语气非常好，但我真的很高兴你不会用那种语气录完剩下的播客。不，我不会。这很重要，因为这些基本上帮助爱德华推翻莫蒂默的家伙们，将在他统治的故事中扮演关键角色。他没有忘记他欠他们的情。这就好像是橄榄球队赢得了什么比赛一样。橄榄球队赢了能得到什么？
Cuppers. There is an Oxford and Cambridge and Oxford rugby match. They're blues. Total lads. So Edward is, you know, he's putting things back together. And at the same time as England is starting to recover its mojo, things are going really badly wrong in France. This is great news.
卡珀斯杯。牛津和剑桥有一场牛津橄榄球赛。他们是“蓝色”队员。纯粹的小伙子。所以爱德华，你知道的，他在把事情重新整合起来。就在英国开始恢复元气的同时，法国的情况却急转直下。这真是个好消息。
So the thing I always remember from The Distant Mirror, and it's very dramatically done, is that, and you mentioned this earlier, that as Jacques de Molay, the head of the Templars, is being burned on the orders of Philip IV in front of Notre Dame, the story is that he curses Philip IV and summons him to meet with Jacques de Molay before God's judgment seat, before the end of the year. And eight months later, sure enough, Philip dies. The power of the Templars, Tom! Yeah! And Tuckman writes wonderfully about this. And eight months later, sure enough, Philip dies. The power of the Templars, Tom. Yeah. And Tuckman writes wonderfully about this.
所以，我从《远方之镜》中永远记得、而且描写得非常戏剧化的一件事是，正如你刚才提到的，当圣殿骑士团团长雅克·德·莫莱奉腓力四世之命在巴黎圣母院前被烧死时，传说他诅咒了腓力四世，并传唤他在年底前去上帝的审判台前与雅克·德·莫莱会面。八个月后，果不其然，腓力死了。圣殿骑士团的力量，汤姆！是的！巴巴拉·塔克曼对此进行了精彩的描写。八个月后，果不其然，腓力死了。圣殿骑士团的力量，汤姆。是的。巴巴拉·塔克曼对此进行了精彩的描写。
Toward contemporaries, the cause was indubitably the Templars' curse that had floated upward with the smoke from the pyre in the red light of the setting sun. So you can see why I like that book. And straight away, the Capetian line, which had been so fertile, succeeding son, succeeding son, it starts to wither. This is so Game of Thrones. Philip IV has three sons. They all succeed each other in rapid succession, and none of them have any sons. The first of them is a guy called Louis, Louis X. He rules for just under two years. So he does have two children. And the first of these, Jean I, John, brilliantly, this is something very weird that happens twice. He's born posthumously five months after his father's death. So everyone's waiting to see if it's going to be a
在当代人看来，其起因无疑是圣殿骑士团的诅咒，它随着夕阳红光中火堆上升的烟雾飘荡开来。所以你可以看出为什么我喜欢那本书。紧接着，曾经枝繁叶茂、子嗣绵延的卡佩王朝开始枯萎。这太像《权力的游戏》了。腓力四世有三个儿子。他们相继快速即位，但都没有留下任何儿子。他们当中的第一个是个叫路易的人，路易十世。他统治了不到两年。所以他确实有两个孩子。而其中的第一个，约翰一世，让，妙就妙在——这是一件非常诡异、而且发生了两次的事情。他在他父亲死后五个月遗腹出生。所以每个人都在等着看这会是一个
boy. It is a boy, but he only rules for five days before dying. So that is officially the shortest reign in French history. I mean, that is short, but also he's only a baby when he... Yes. I mean, you pop out and then you die. And that's basically the limit of your reign. Yeah. He lives for five days and reigns for five days. Is that right? Yes. Five eventful days anyway. Who's going to succeed him? He has a sister who's four years old at the time called Joan. But she gets, you know, you can't have a four-year-old girl. So she
男孩吗？是个男孩，但他只统治了五天就死了。所以这官方成为了法国历史上最短的统治期。我的意思是，这真的很短，而且他出生时也只是个婴儿……是的。我的意思是，你刚生出来然后就死了。这基本上就是你统治的极限了。是的。他活了五天，也统治了五天。是这样吗？是的。不管怎样，那是充满变数的五天。谁来继承他的王位？他当时有一个四岁的妹妹叫琼。但她被，你知道的，你不能让一个四岁的女孩来统治，所以她
gets elbowed aside by her uncle, who then rules as Philip V. He rules for six years. He dies, then gets succeeded by his brother, younger brother Charles IV, who again rules for six years, dies in 1322. And with his death, there are no more Capetians. So then the question is, who is going to rule? Who's going to succeed? So there are three candidates. Right. Because France is the big prize now. I mean, everybody wants- France is the big prize, yeah. So there is a grandson of Philip IV. Well, that's good news. And that is Edward III. Of course, through Isabella. So you've had Louis, Philip, and Charles, the three kings of France who've all just died, and Isabella, who's their sister. But this is
被她的叔叔挤到了一边，后者随后以腓力五世的身份统治。他统治了六年。他死了，然后由他的弟弟、更小的弟弟查理四世继承王位，查理四世同样统治了六年，于1322年去世。随着他的去世，再也没有卡佩王朝的直系后裔了。于是问题来了，谁来统治？谁来继承？所以有三个候选人。没错。因为法国现在成了最大的战利品。我的意思是，每个人都想——法国是最大的战利品，是的。所以有一个腓力四世的外孙。哦，那是好消息。那就是爱德华三世。当然，是通过伊莎贝拉。所以你们有了路易、腓力、查理，这三个刚刚去世的法国国王，而伊莎贝拉是他们的姐姐。但这
terrible from the point of view of the French. They don't want the King of England. They don't know him. He's the King of England. It's no good. And so they basically say, well, you've inherited the throne from a woman. That's no good. Even though that's not the law at all. They're just making that up. They've made up this new, that's the Salic law, right? Salic law comes in later, but retrospectively it gets fitted to that. That's what it comes to be cast as. But this is a complete and utter con. I mean, he should have been the king. He has a very good claim to it. Yes. Great. Good. I'm glad we've established that.
从法国人的角度来看太可怕了。他们不想要英国国王。他们不认识他。他是英国国王。这不行。所以他们基本上说，嗯，你是从一个女人那里继承的王位。这不行。尽管这根本不符合法律。他们纯粹是胡编乱造。他们编造了这套新规矩，那就是萨利克法，对吧？萨利克法是后来才出现的，但它是被追溯适用到那上面的。这就是它后来的定性。但这完全是一场彻头彻尾的骗局。我的意思是，他本该成为国王的。他对此有着非常正当的继承权。是的。太好了。很好。我很高兴我们确立了这一点。
But Philip IV, the grandfather of Edward III, he had a brother and a half-brother. Yeah. So the half-brother is a guy called, so confusing, they're all called Philip. Don't tell me they're both called Philip, are they? Yeah, they're both called Philip. I'm really sorry about this. Come on. So Philip of Evero. So why have him when you can have a full brother? So he's the half brother. He's the half brother. So he doesn't get it. And he gets recompensed for this by being given the kingdom of Navarre, which is in the Pyrenees.
但是腓力四世，也就是爱德华三世的外祖父，他有一个兄弟和一个同母异父的兄弟。是的。所以那个同母异父的兄弟是个叫——太令人困惑了，他们都叫腓力。别告诉我他们两个都叫腓力，是吗？是的，他们俩都叫腓力。对此我真的很抱歉。拜托。所以是埃夫勒的腓力。那么，既然能选一个同父同母的兄弟，为什么还要选他呢？所以他是同母异父的兄弟。他是同母异父的兄弟。所以他没有得到王位。作为补偿，他得到了位于比利牛斯山的纳瓦拉王国。
That's lovely. I would take Navarre. Yeah. And he gets married to Joan. Joan is the four-year-old. The four-year-old granddaughter of Philip IV. And that's important because it means that their children, if they have sons, they will potentially have a claim on the throne. So remember, if Joan has a son, he will be in a position to create mischief. Is this a point at which listeners should start making notes? Yeah. I want them to bear that in mind. The other one, so the brother is Philip of Valois. Yeah. that in mind the other one so the brother is philip of valois yeah and he is the guy who serves as regent charles the fourth's widow is also pregnant okay when charles the fourth dies and so again everyone is waiting to see you know will it be a son because if it's a son then the
那太棒了。我要纳瓦拉。是的。他娶了琼。琼就是那个四岁的女孩。腓力四世四岁的孙女。这很重要，因为这意味着他们的孩子，如果他们有儿子的的话，将潜在地对王位拥有继承权。所以记住，如果琼生了个儿子，他将处于能够兴风作浪的地位。现在是听众们该开始做笔记的时候了吗？是的。我希望他们把这一点记在心里。另一个人，所以那个兄弟是瓦卢瓦的腓力。是的。
problem is solved but it isn't it's a daughter oh so she's no good yeah so she's no good and so philip of Valois then becomes Philip VI. He seizes the throne. He doesn't seize the throne. I mean, basically he's- The French want him to be king. The French want him to be king because he's an experienced soldier. He's not a newborn girl. You say he's an experienced soldier, Tom, but is he an experienced soldier in the same way that Liz Truss is a well-known prime minister? Because Jonathan Sumption describes him as a thoroughly bad soldier. I mean, you can be experienced and bad, can't you?
把这一点记在心里，另一个人，所以这个兄弟是瓦卢瓦的腓力。是的，他就是担任摄政王的那个人。查理四世的遗孀当时也怀孕了，好吧。在查理四世死后，所以同样每个人都在等待，你知道的，会是个儿子吗？因为如果是儿子，那么问题就解决 了，但事实并非如此，是个女儿。哦，所以她不行。是的，所以她不行，因此瓦卢瓦的腓力随后成为了腓力六世。他夺取了王位。他并没有夺取王位。我的意思是，基本上他是——法国人希望他成为国王。法国人希望他成为国王，因为他是一个经验丰富的士兵。他可不是一个刚出生的女婴。你说他是一个经验丰富的士兵，汤姆，但他是一个经验丰富的士兵，就像莉兹·特拉斯是一个著名的首相那样吗？因为乔纳森·萨姆森将他描述为一个极其糟糕的士兵。我的意思是，你既可以经验丰富又很糟糕，对吧？
Yeah. So Jonathan Sumption, who's written a series of exhaustive histories of the Hundred Years' War, describes him as the worst soldier, more so than any other medieval king of France, except perhaps for the mentally defective Charles VI. He's also depressive. He's also increasingly obese. Frassat says of him that he was always ready to take the advice of fools. So perhaps again, a Liz Truss comparison there. His wife, Joan of Burgundy, is a famous intellectual and therefore is loathed and detested by all the chroniclers of the age. And so she's known as the lame evil queen. The Virginia Woolf of medieval France, Tom. So basically, Philip of Valois has become Philip VI and has beaten Edward III to the crown. And if people know about the Hundred Years' War, what they might think is that this is the cause
是的。所以乔纳森·萨姆森，他写了一系列关于百年战争的详尽历史著作，将他描述为最糟糕的士兵，比任何其他中世纪的法国国王都要糟糕，也许除了精神上有缺陷的查理六世。他也很抑郁。他也越来越胖。 Froissart 评价他说，他总是准备听取傻瓜的建议。所以也许在这里又可以和莉兹·特拉斯做个对比。他的妻子勃艮第的琼是一位著名的知识分子，因此被那个时代的所有编年史家所厌恶和痛恨。所以她被称为“跛足邪恶王后”。中世纪法国的弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，汤姆。所以基本上，瓦卢瓦的腓力成了腓力六世，并且击败了爱德华三世登上了王位。如果人们对百年战争有所了解，他们可能会认为这就是百年战争的起因。这是爱德华对此感到生气。但事实并非如此。爱德华确实接受了腓力六世为国王。事实上，一向倾向于反叛法国国王的弗兰德斯人，他们发生了一场叛乱，他们说，看，我们承认你为国王。而爱德华三世拒绝了他们。为什么？因为，嗯，因为他的母亲伊莎贝拉仍然活跃在政坛上。她其实并不赞同这一点。而且还因为他正忙着试图稳定英国的局势。
of the Hundred Years' War. It's Edward being cross about it. That's not actually the case. Edward does accept Philip VI as king. And actually, the Flemings, who are always prone to rebelling against the French king, they have a rebellion and they say, look, we'll acknowledge you as king. And Edward III turns them down. Why? Because, well, because Isabella, his mother, is still very much on the scene. She doesn't really approve of it. But also because he's busy trying to stabilize England.
他没有时间急急忙忙去入侵法国什么的。因为试图做到这一点是一件大事，试图对抗法国。这是一件大事。但问题是，一旦腓力成了国王，他就在不断地宣示存在感、确立自己的威望。因此，他开始在爱德华三世面前摆谱。他传唤爱德华来向他宣誓效忠。而正如我所说，依然活跃在政坛上的伊莎贝拉对此极其蔑视。她回复腓力说，她的儿子是国王的儿子，因此不会向一个伯爵的儿子宣誓效忠。好样的，伊莎贝拉。她在我的心目中地位上升了。
He doesn't have time to go rushing off to invade France or anything. Because to try and do this is a massive deal to try and take on the French. It's a massive deal. But the problem is, is that once Philip has become king, he is in the business of laying down markers, establishing his prestige. And so he starts to throw his weight around relative to Edward III. He summons Edward to come and do him homage. And Isabella, who's still, as I said, very much on the scene, is wildly contemptuous of this. She replies to Philip that her son is the son of a king and therefore will not do homage to the son of a count. Good for Isabella. She's gone up in
所以腓力面对这种拒绝，做了腓力四世曾经做过的事，那就是威胁要没收加斯科涅。因此爱德华还没有准备好防御加斯科涅免受这一威胁。所以在1329年，他非常勉强地穿过海峡，前往他的领地蓬蒂厄，向南朝巴黎进发，路过了宏伟的克雷西森林。哦，汤姆，这是一个非常好的伏笔。也许是在那里侦察地形。他宣誓效忠的方式没有承认腓力是他的封建领主。宣誓效忠有两种方式。而他宣誓效忠的方式没有承认腓力是他的封建领主。所以宣誓效忠有两种方式。他选择了不那么尴尬的那一种。然后他去参加了腓力在亚眠举办的比武大会。他当时16岁，
my estimation. So Philip, faced by this refusal, does what Philip IV had done, which is threaten to confiscate Gascony. And so Edward is not yet in a position to defend Gascony against this threat. And so very reluctantly in 1329, he crosses the channel, he goes to Pontieux, his holding, heads south towards Paris, going past the great forest of Crecy. Oh, Tom, that's a very nice bit of foreshadowing. Maybe scoping out the lie of the land there. And he does homage in such a way as not to acknowledge that Philip is his liege lord. So there are two ways of doing homage. And he does homage in such a way as not to acknowledge that Philip is his liege lord. So there are two ways of doing homage. And he does the less embarrassing form. And he then goes to a tournament that Philip holds at Amiens. He's 16 at this point,
表现得惊艳全场。他在比武大会中表现得极为出色。哦，好样的，爱德华。所以事情似乎走上了稳定的轨道。法国和英国似乎成了朋友。关于谁是法国国王并没有真正的争端。事情似乎进展顺利，但英国和法国的关系中仍然存在两个巨大的疮疤，那就是苏格兰——苏格兰人听到你把他们描述为一个巨大的疮疤一定会非常高兴，汤姆。还有加斯科涅。好吧。加斯科涅人同上。
and he absolutely smashes it. He does brilliantly well in the tournament. Oh, good for Edward. So things might seem on a stable footing. France and England seem to be friends. There's no real debate over who's the King of France. Things might seem to be going well, but there remain two massive sores in the relationship between England and France, and they are Scotland- The Scots will be delighted to hear you describe them as a massive sore, Tom. And Gascony. Okay. Ditto the Gascons.
所以苏格兰依然是自1296年签署条约以来一直那样的状态，是法国国王对英国施加压力的一种方式。是的。爱德华深知这一点。他对莫蒂默签署的条约感到愤恨，所以他的首要任务基本上就是废除它。他是这样做的，还记得约翰·巴里奥吗？他原本是苏格兰国王，由爱德华一世任命。他的儿子想要去夺回王位。所以当约翰·巴里奥的儿子带着一帮冒险者从诺森伯利亚入侵苏格兰时，爱德华睁一只眼闭一只眼，他干得极其出色。
So Scotland remains what it has been since the signing of the treaty back in 1296, a way for the French kings to apply pressure to England. Yeah. And Edward knows this. He's resentful of the treaty that Mortimer had signed, and so his priority basically is to repudiate that. And he does this by, you remember John Balliol, who was originally the King of Scotland, appointed by Edward I. His son wants to go and reclaim the throne. So Edward turns a blind eye when John Balliol's son invades Scotland from Northumbria, taken with a band of adventurers, and he does tremendously well.
他的目标基本上是推翻罗伯特·布鲁斯的五岁儿子戴维二世。一开始进展顺利，后来却急转直下。到1333年，一支庞大的苏格兰军队抵达特威德河畔并正在围攻贝里克。爱德华三世急忙赶去救援，因为这，他能够将这伪装成是对英国的入侵。他在离萨迪从她父亲那里继承的、位于特威德河畔的漂亮小屋几英里远的一个叫哈利顿山的地方与苏格兰军队会合。来自荷兰乡间别墅，汤姆，我喜欢这样认为。这是在我们的乡间别墅里。我很惭愧地说，我其实从来没有参观过哈利顿山战役的遗址，下次我们去那边的时候我一定要去。无论如何，这是一场令人振奋的伟大胜利。爱德华彻底击溃了他们。戴维二世不得不逃往法国。这彻底毒化了英法关系，因为根据英苏协议的条款，腓力六世必须支持戴维二世并让他重登王位。理所当然。所以这对法国人来说极具挑衅性。是的。因此，当戴维二世抵达法国请求法国支持时，英国大使——事实上是坎特伯雷大主教——当时正在巴黎。好吧，他不在，因为他才五岁，但跟他一起去的那些人都在。于是腓力六世通知英国大使，除非把苏格兰包含在内并维护苏格兰的权利，否则英法之间不会有任何条约。这其实非常脱欧。这非常脱欧，汤姆。北爱尔兰议定书的等价物正在阻碍一项英法条约的签署。是的。所以本质上，爱德华三世面临着这样的抉择：要么放弃他对苏格兰的主张，要么拿加斯科涅的安全去冒险。因为很显然，如果没有与法国国王签署条约，那么法国人就会觉得他们有权去占领加斯科涅。所以这是一个他必须做出的非常艰难的决定。但因为他是个纯粹的小伙子，他拒绝妥协。
His aim basically is to topple the five-year-old son of Robert Bruce, David II. It goes very well to begin with, and then it goes very badly. By 1333, a large Scottish army has arrived on the banks of the Tweed and are besieging Berwick. Edward III goes rushing up to the rescue because this is, he's able to cast this as an invasion of England. He meets with the Scottish army at a place called Halladon Hill, which is a few miles from where Sadie was inherited from her father, a bonny cottage on the banks of the Tweed. From the Holland country estate, Tom, as I like to think of it. It's in our country estate. And I'm ashamed to say I've never actually visited the site of the
所以基本上他说，好吧，我要坚持我对苏格兰的主张。如果你攻击加斯科涅，我就会为此开战。英法关系陷入了一种螺旋式下降的恶性循环。因此到了1336年，也就是苏格兰国王逃往法国两年后，整个英国都陷入了大规模的入侵恐慌中。他们开始构筑烽火台。他们试图拼凑船只来防卫海峡，诸如此类。与此同时，法国国王正在制定一项极其复杂且从长远来看流产了的计划，企图通过苏格兰入侵英国。这简直太疯狂了。这是一种非常复杂的方式。所以这对于爱德华来说看起来非常非常糟糕，面临着直接入侵的威胁。然后在1337年5月，
Battle of Halladon Hill, and I'll be doing it the next time we go up there. Anyway, it's an absolutely zinging victory. Edward absolutely crushes it. David II has to escape to France. This absolutely poisons Anglo-French relations because by the terms of the Scottish-French agreement, Philip VI has to back David II and get him back on the throne. Of course. So this is very provocative to the French. Yeah. So English ambassadors are, in fact, the Archbishop of Canterbury are in Paris at the time when David II arrives in France asking for French support. Well, he's not because he's five, but the guys have gone with him. And so Philip VI informs the English ambassadors that there will be no treaty
腓力宣布他正在没收阿基坦公国。这实际上就是宣战。没错，因为爱德华必须对此作出回应。好吧，于是爱德华去了议会，得到了议会的大力支持，拉拢了英国所有的贵族站在他这一边。他绝对确保自己不仅仅是将这视为一场个人的王朝战争，他确保自己也把英国的贵族和议会争取到了自己这边。1337年8月28日，他发表了一份公开宣言，指责腓力通过支持苏格兰人来挑起战争，公然无视他在苏格兰的权利，支持法国船只对英国海岸进行海盗式袭击，以及行为不端
between England and France unless Scotland is included and Scottish rights are upheld. So it's actually very Brexit. It's very Brexit, Tom. The equivalent of the Northern Ireland Protocol is getting in the way of an Anglais-French treaty. Yeah. And so essentially, Edward III is faced with the choice of abandoning his Scottish claim or risking the security of Gascony. Because obviously, if no treaty is signed with the French king, then the French will feel that they have the right to go and appropriate Gascony. So it's a very difficult decision that he has to make. But because he's an absolute lad, he refuses to compromise.
剥夺了他在阿基坦的祖传权利。所以非常有趣的是，他觉得有必要发表一份公开宣言，因为对百年战争的刻板印象是这只是骑士和男爵们之间的事。但他觉得他需要争取平民的支持。他绝对这么做了。是的。所以你认为这是为什么？部分是因为爱德华意识到，英国人的身份认同比法国人的身份认同更加凝聚。
And so essentially he says, well, I'm going to uphold my claims on Scotland. If you attack Gascony, I'm going to go to war over it. And relations between England and France go into a kind of downward spiral. So by 1336, so that's two years after the Scottish king has fled to France, the whole of England is having a massive invasion scare. They're kind of building beacons. They're trying to kind of rustle up ships to defend the channel, all this kind of thing. And the French kings, meanwhile, is drawing up this incredibly complicated and in the long run, abortive plan to invade England through Scotland. which is kind of mad. It's a very complicated way of doing it. So that's looking very, very bad for Edward, the threat of direct invasion. And then in May 1337,
并且如果他能动员广大英国民众，让他们觉得他的事业就是英国的事业，那么这显然会很棒。他之所以意识到有必要这样做，是因为爱德华知道他有一个秘密武器，那就是一种令人难以置信的全新军事技术，他其实在对阵苏格兰人的哈利顿山战役中已经释放过这种技术了。所以他知道它是毁灭性的，那就是长弓。我们大概应该把这个留到下一集的讨论中。但重申一下，爱德华的宣战，他准备捍卫自己对抗法国君主的权利，是非常非常强硬的。我的意思是，这相当于，
Philip declares that he is confiscating the Duchy of Aquitaine. And this effectively is a declaration of war. Right, because Edward has to respond to that. Well, so Edward goes to Parliament, gets the backing of Parliament, gets all the peers of England on side. He's absolutely making sure that he's not just treating this as a personal dynastic war. He's making sure that he's getting the peers and the Parliament of England on side as well. On the 28th of August, 1337, he issues a public manifesto in which he accuses Philip of provoking war by supporting the Scots in defiance of his rights in Scotland, of supporting French ships in their piratical raids on the English coast, and of behaving unlawfully
在乌克兰战争爆发前夕，如果乌克兰基本上对俄罗斯开战并入侵了俄罗斯。这就是那种强硬程度。所以这是一个弱小的一方、处于劣势的一方说：“好吧，我们上吧。大干一场吧。我可不坐在那里等着被像狗一样强大的对手攻击。”而爱德华的策略绝对是将战争带到法国本土。换句话说，他知道如果法国人在英国建立桥头堡，那么他们毁灭英国的能力将是压倒性的。但如果他能清除法国对海峡的控制，并在法国建立永久的桥头堡，将战争打到法国去，那么这就能确保英国免受战争之苦。所以这基本上就是他的策略。
in stripping him of his ancestral rights in Aquitaine. So it's really interesting that he feels the need to issue a public manifesto that this is an age, because the stereotype of the Hundred Years' War is this is just knights and barons among themselves. But he feels he needs to get the commons. He absolutely does. Yeah. So why is that, do you think? It's in part because Edward can recognize that English identity is something more coherent, say, than French identity.
但它仍然非常非常强硬。随着战争的开始，人们所问的问题不是，他能赢吗？不是，他能让自己成为法国国王吗？而是他如何能避免法国人的入侵？他如何能避免加斯科涅乃至英国的征服？基本上欧洲几乎所有人都预期他会输。天哪。以一个多么戏剧性的时刻结束啊，汤姆。因为这只是四期播客中的第一期，对吧？是的。
And that if he can rally the mass of the English to a sense that his cause is England's cause, then obviously that'll be great. And the reason that he is aware of the need to do that is that Edward knows he has a secret weapon in the form of an incredible new military technology, which he had actually unleashed at the Battle of Halladon Hill against the Scots. And so he knows it's devastating, which is the longbow. And we should probably save that for a discussion in the next episode. But just to reiterate, Edward's declaration of war, his readiness to uphold his rights against the French monarchy is very, very punchy. I mean, it's equivalent, say,
被捕的历史俱乐部的成员们，如果你们对长弓、弱者的胜利、在压倒性的邪恶面前表现出的巨大英雄主义的故事感兴趣的话。黑太子，红雪貂。没错。他们现在就可以收听剩下的剧集了。普通的听众。我的意思是，如果你想成为一个普通人，当普通人也没什么不好的。这是一个漫长的时刻，而不是一个夜晚。
in the buildup to the Ukraine war, if Ukraine had basically gone to war with Russia and invaded Russia. It's that level of punchiness. So it's the smaller, the underdog just saying, right, let's go for it. Let's get stuck in. I'm not waiting to be attacked by the bigger dog as it were. And Edward's strategy is absolutely to take the war to France. So in other words, he knows that if the French get a toehold in England, then their capacity to devastate England will be overwhelming. But that if he can clear French control of the Channel and establish permanent footholds in France and take the war to France, then that will keep England secure from the war. So that is basically its strategy.
他们可以，嗯，他们基本上得等到周四。但你可以通过在 restishistorypod.com 注册来现在收听。让我再告诉你一件事，如果你那样做了，你将会得到什么。每一集，你都会得到一段来自阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士的《奈杰尔爵士》的精彩朗读，因为这就是我们将如何向这个系列引入未来剧集的方式。所以你不仅能品尝到由汤姆·霍兰德带来的伟大历史，还能品尝到由阿瑟·柯南·道尔和我带来的高水平文学创作。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，我们下期将带着《长弓》回归。我们接下来要讲哪场战役？我们要讲的是斯鲁伊斯海战，
But it's still very, very punchy. And the question that people are asking as the war begins isn't, can he win? It isn't, can he make himself King of France? It's how can he avoid a French evasion? How can he avoid the conquest of Gascony and maybe even England? And basically pretty much everyone in Europe is expecting him to lose. Crikey. What a dramatic moment on which to end, Tom. Because this is just the first of four podcasts, isn't it? It is.
那是一场伟大的海军胜利。我们要讲克雷西战役，这基本上就是中世纪的特拉法尔加海战。我们还要讲英国人攻占加莱。还有无数的骑士精神、骑士、少女、红雪貂，应有尽有。我的意思是，如果你是个法国人，你肯定不会想听。但如果你是个英国人，你绝对会听。是的，既然我们没有法国听众，谁在乎呢？带着这个重磅消息，我们下期再见。再见。
Arrested History Club members who are interested in longbows, underdog victories, stories of tremendous heroism against overwhelming evil. Black princes, red ferrets. Exactly. They can listen to the rest of the episodes now. Ordinary listeners. I mean, there's nothing bad about being ordinary if that's what you want to be. A long moment rather than a night.
拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishtertainment.com。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
They can, well, they have to wait till Thursday, basically. But you can listen now by signing up at restishistorypod.com. And let me tell you one more thing that you will be getting if you do that. You will get, with each episode, a lovely reading from Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's Sir Nigel, because that's how we'll be introducing future episodes to this series. So you'll get a taste, not just of great history, courtesy of Tom Holland, but a fantastic high-level literary craftsmanship, courtesy of Sir Arthur Conan Doyle and me. So on that bombshell, Tom, we return next time with The Longbow. What battle have we got coming up? We've got the Battle of Sluice,
他们可以，嗯，基本上得等到周四。不过你现在就可以通过在 restishistorypod.com 注册来收听。让我再告诉你一件事，如果你这么做了，你会得到什么。每集节目中，你都会听到亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士的小说《骑士奈杰尔》的精彩朗读，因为这就是我们将如何把未来的节目引入这个系列的方式。所以你不仅能品味到由汤姆·霍兰德带来的伟大历史，还能领略到由亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士和我共同呈现的高超文学手艺。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，我们下次将带着《长弓》回归。我们接下来要讲什么战役？我们要讲的是斯鲁伊斯海战，
which is a great naval victory. We've got the Battle of Crecy, which is basically the medieval Battle of Trafalgar. And we've got the capture of Calais by the English. And loads of gallantry, knights, maidens, red ferrets, you name it. I mean, basically, if you're French, you won't want to listen to it. But if you're English, you definitely will. Yeah, since we don't have any French listeners, who cares? And on that bombshell, we'll see you next time. Goodbye.
这是一场伟大的海军大捷。我们有克雷西战役，这基本上就是中世纪的特拉法尔加海战。我们还有英军攻占加来。还有无数的骑士风度、骑士、少女、红雪貂，应有尽有。我的意思是，基本上，如果你是法国人，你肯定不想听。但如果你是英国人，你绝对会想听。是的，既然我们没有法国听众，谁在乎呢？带着这个重磅消息，我们下次再见。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishtertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。